c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la situation est sous
contrôle en guinée-bissau c'est en tout
cas ce qu'a affirmé le président aime
ballots sur les réseaux sociaux et
devant la presse en début d'après midi
des tirs ont été signalés dans le
centre-ville près du palais du
gouvernement la cedeao condamne une
tentative de coup d'état
les concertations entre représentants de
partis à politique et le pouvoir
militaire au burkina faso le nouvel
homme fort du pays le colonel damiba
elle les invite à faire preuve de
responsabilité et de retenue les détails
dans ce journal
je vais bien la situation est sous
contrôle gouvernemental c'est ce qu'a
fait oui tu es le président umaru
sissoko et mballo ce soir des photos de
lui avec les militaires ont également
été posté sur sa page facebook et il
s'est également exprimé devant la presse
sont les premiers éléments le concernant
depuis cet après midi nous avons nous
même tenté de le joindre à plusieurs
reprises sans y parvenir la situation
était très confuse après des échanges
des échanges de tirs près du palais du
gouvernement retour sur les événements
avec amy mbaye ça
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux kumar ou
sissoko et mballo a donné de ses
nouvelles sur ces clichés postés sur la
page facebook de la présidence on voit
le chef d'état de la guinée-bissau
entouré par son service de sécurité
sur twitter il affirme que la situation
dans le pays est désormais sous contrôle
c'est pourtant la confusion qui régnait
toute la journée dans la capitale en
milieu d'après midi des tirs nourris ont
été entendus dans le secteur du palais
du gouvernement sur ces vidéos amateurs
on peut voir le bâtiment encerclé par
des hommes lourdement armés au moment
des faits le palais accueillait un
conseil des ministres extraordinaire en
présence du président donc et de son
premier ministre le spectre d'un putsch
plane rapidement dans le pays des écoles
et marchés de la claque pepy fermés et
des cordons armés ont été déployés
autour de bâtiments officiels dans une
conférence de presse donnée dans la
soirée le président a annoncé que ce
coup d'état avorté a fait plusieurs
victimes du côté des forces de sécurité
en ajoutant que les membres du
gouvernement s'en sont sortis indemnes
je lisais le président mba l'eau a
également pris la parole devant la
presse ce soir il a évoqué une tentative
de coup d'état et affirmé que la
situation était sous contrôle résumé de
sa déclaration avec notre correspondante
dans la région sarrassat coup le
président mba l'eau est apparu dans la
grande salle du palais devant un
parterre de journalistes et il avait les
traits tirés l'air fatigué secoué par
par cet après midi donc de tentative de
coup d'état alors il l'a tout de suite
dit qu'il était enfermé 5 heures durant
il a s'est voulu rassurant d'abord en
expliquant que le calme était revenu et
puis il a dit c'est bien une tentative
de coup d'état militaire à la raison
selon lui et bien c'est le
mécontentement par rapport à la lutte
qu'il a menée contre la corruption et
donc le trafic de drogue c'est en tout
cas ce qu'il a exprimé devant la devant
la presse selon lui des civils également
seraient impliquées n'a pas donné de
précisions sur leur identité il a
également parlé de mort encore une fois
sans donner plus d'information combien
de qui s'agit-il il n'a pas précisé cela
et puis également d'arrestation autres
informations et évidemment aucun détail
non plus sur l'identité des assaillants
des militaires certes mais de quel corps
lille n'a pas voulu s'étendre sur ce sur
ce sujet là en tout cas il l'a dit
l'ordre est revenu à bissao il a
également parlé de la clameur des
populations des messages d'encouragement
des populations qu'il a reçus donc alors
qu'ils regagnaient le palais
présidentiel voilà pour l'essentiel de
cette allocution qui a eu lieu il ya
quelques minutes au palais présidentiel
devant donc des journalistes
depuis l'indépendance du pays en 1960 14
ans relève quatre coups d'état et 17
tentatives de coups d'état josé mario
vaz est le seul président élu depuis
l'instauration du pluripartisme qui soit
parvenu à finir son mandat
marot cissokho m bales au président en
fonction est arrivé au pouvoir en
janvier 2020 cela fait deux ans que cet
ancien général et aux manettes son
portrait signé shirli sitôt
son arrivée au pouvoir fin 2019 était
mouvementée
candidats de l'opposition l'ancien
premier ministre et ancien général de
brigade oumaro sissoko embalo est
déclaré vainqueur par la commission
électorale mais son rival est le parti
majoritaire au parlement conteste le
résultat et on appelle qu'à la cour
suprême qui demande une vérification
officiel finalement oumar aussi ce
courant balou est investi en même temps
qu'un autre président par intérim qui
finit par démissionner sous la pression
la cedeao proteste le nouveau président
avance avec une volonté affichée
d'affronter la corruption et le trafic
de drogue
tombé à 11 ans
là bas qu'on m'a dit
et tu auras ça sert pas comme ça
[Musique]
car le petit pays qu'est la
guinée-bissau est devenu depuis des
décennies une plaque tournante de la
drogue le nouveau président de ce pays à
l'histoire mouvementée avec quatre coups
d'état depuis son indépendance du
portugal en 1974 s'engage
personnellement dans la diplomatie pour
relancer l'économie notamment il invite
son homologue portugais pour la première
fois ont plus de 30 ans il est accueilli
à l'elysée en octobre dernier où le
président emmanuel macron la sueur du
soutien de la france pour le
développement de son pays déjà alors
qu'il est à paris des responsables
alerte depuis la guinée-bissau sur une
première tentative de coup
et on retrouve tout de suite notre
invité ce soir mahamat saleh annadif
envoyé spécial de l'onu pour l'afrique
de l'ouest bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous j'aimerais tout d'abord vous faire
réagir sur les événements en
guinée-bissau cette nouvelle tentative
de coup d'état dans la région vous
inquiète elle
subir au mali en guinée et ce sont deux
choses que nous à voir qu'on
est en tout cas les coups d'état ne sort
pas du tout et ne peuvent pas
alors vous avez cités vous avez cité le
mali 1 depuis mai 2021 le coup d'état
dans le coup d'état on a assisté
également des prises de pouvoir illégale
au tchad en guinée au soudan au burkina
faso comment expliquez vous cette
contagion la communauté internationale
n'était pas assez ferme assez dissuasive
n'est ce pas un échec finalement
les coups d'état respectifs de répéter
ce qui s'est passé pour que la personne
ne sont pas acceptables que son parti
sera
aussi bien régionaux sur les jeunots à
savoir l'union africaine et la cedeao
pour faire en sorte que ils tirent des
coups d'état est
alors monsieur matte saleh annadif on a
également parlé du burkina faso vous
étiez à à ouagadougou hier aujourd'hui
des représentants des partis toutes
tendances confondues ont été reçus au
palais de kossyam dans le cadre de
concertation voulue par le pouvoir
militaire depuis plusieurs jours le
nouvel homme fort du pays paul henri
damiba les a invités à faire preuve de
responsabilité et de retenue il les a
également invités à accompagner la jante
dans ce processus et apporter leur
contribution si nécessaire eddie
komboïgo président du cdp et ex chef de
file de l'opposition à participer à
cette rencontre je vous propose de
l'écouter il répondait aux questions de
notre correspondant à ouagadougou
kalidou sy
il nous a simplement rappelé les raisons
qui les ont conduits à agir parce que
c'était un coup d'état vous connaissez
la situation de notre pays qui est un
point 2-2 guerre des terroristes il
était de leur devoir patriotique
d'intervenir dans la vie de la nation
pour sauver la nation nous avons
souhaité nous enquérir à titre
humanitaire
le savoir l'état de santé de l'ancien
président marc christian kaboré je les
ai vus nous avons échangé il nous a
certainement dès qu'il est en bonne
santé et elle nous avons constaté et se
repose un peu mieux elle nous a hélas
également nous a assuré que la décision
de démissionner était personnelle ce qui
compte pour mes bottines a b c la fin de
la guerre et si les pays membres de la
cedeao ou pouvaient s'unir combattre le
terrorisme
ce qui est arrivé ne serez pas mais
je reviens vers vous à mahamat saleh
annadif je le disais vous étiez à
ouagadougou hier vous avez rencontré le
nouvel homme fort du pays et le
président déchu roch kaboré tout d'abord
comment va-t-il est il libre de ses
mouvements
oui comme les
conjoints de la paix des nations unies
nous sommes une mission d'évaluation
ils sont partis écouter le nouvel
autorités
[Musique]
et nous avons écouté par les auteurs du
coup qu'ils ont expliqué les raisons au
gré des raisons de ce coup nous leur
avons dit de toute façon aux tables pour
autant que la
nana solution n'est pas un coup d'état
dans tous les cas rossi qui a porté une
à cabourg et de la voie et qu'il
faudrait avoir pour ma et de continent à
sortir de la crise qu'elle traverse ils
nous ont dit
répandre sa part des concertations et
qu'ils vont revenir vers la cedeao et la
communauté
internationale avec
free d'où leur permettra de discuter
avec
et la cedeao donc en position de force
alors quelle a été votre message le chef
de la junte désormais au pouvoir
notre message quand j'ai vu tout à
l'heure
maintenant il faut tout faire pour
proposer
travaux précisé deux parties
pour régler tous les problèmes et pour
cela nous avons fait tout ce qu'on peut
dire notre
expérience nous avons ces conditions les
plus réalistes les ours n'ont pas non
plus les précipiter à court de solutions
nous en sommes conscients et ce n'est
pas un prêt à porter un coup dur à
chaque auteur des coups d'état en tout
cas la cedeao va créer le toit est payé
et nous encore tout cas examinés en
pliant de notre mission au niveau du
burkina et
la marche à suivre en attendant que
alors dans sa première prise de parole
le colonel damiba a tendu la main à la
communauté internationale le burkina
faso va t'il être sanctionnés au même
titre que le mali
de ne pas voir
[Musique]
en pourparlers avec les nouvelles
autorités ont beau tir et passe aux
élections les fonctions nous engageant
monde il est n'est pas la commission
d'ici là on peut te donne également de
comparer avec une nouvelle nourriture on
va
merci beaucoup mahamat salah saleha
annadif envoyé spécial de l'onu en
afrique de l'ouest merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions pour finir je vous
emmène en afrique du sud en décembre
2021 des activistes ont gagné contre
shell qui explorer les fonds sous-marins
de la province du cap oriental à la
recherche d'hydrocarbures
le géant néerlandais va devoir obtenir
le consentement des communautés
concernées pour reprendre ces
prospections en attendant les activistes
ne baisse pas les bras reportage de
caroline dumas stéphane carstens
les tribunes seront d'aucune utilité ces
terres depuis des siècles quand les
compagnies minières sont venus troubler
leur quiétude
une société australienne a voulu
exploiter le titanium en 2007 les chants
étaient détruits et les villages se sont
organisés pour réagir
les communautés n'était pas d'accord
avec les mineurs alors on les a expulsés
renault terrain offert en 2018 un
jugement de la haute cour sud-africaine
statut est qu'aucune activité minière ne
pouvait être sans le consentement de ce
que vous pouvez
mr n'est pas seulement pour nous un
moyen de gagner notre vie elle fait
partie de notre monde spirituel elle
nous permet de nous régénérer
pour nous les ancêtres vivent dans la
mer
plus récemment ses activistes ont aussi
réussi à immobiliser le bateau de shell
qui effectué des prospection offshore le
géant néerlandais n'avaient pas
suffisamment consultés les communautés
locales shell doit aussi fournir plus
d'informations sur les risques
environnementaux pour cette
documentariste l'exploration sismique de
gaz offshore a d'importantes
conséquences sur la vie marine census la
science montre que le plancton les
coraux ou les crustacés sont menées
toutes les espèces des petites aux
grandes sont touchés
les ondes de choc sont envoyés par des
canons à air qui tirent régulièrement
sur les fonds marins pour en déterminer
la nature géologique
les activistes sud africains demandent à
ce que ce type de prospection soit
interdit sur toutes les côtes du pays
mais pour les responsables de cette
agence gouvernementale on ne peut pas
tout changer du jour au lendemain des
émeutes en grèce
l'importation de gaz et de pétrole est
notre plus grande entrée dans la balance
des paiements pour le gouvernement ce
serait une étape majeure d'arrêter
d'importer et de produire nos propres
hydrocarbures
le gouvernement entend bien renforcer sa
coopération avec les communautés locales
mais les responsables ont fait savoir
que la recherche d'hydrocarbures
continuerai avant de se quitter je vous
rappelle l'information principale de ce
journal je vais bien la situation est
sous contrôle gouvernemental c'est ce
qu'a twitté le président omar ou sissoko
et mballo ce soir des photos de lui avec
les militaires ont également été posté
sur sa page facebook il s'est également
exprimé devant la presse ce sont les
premiers éléments le concernant depuis
cet après midi la situation était très
confuse après des échanges de tirs près
du palais du gouvernement
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régime
merci à célia karacena notre chef
d'édition et merci à vous pour votre
fidélité restez avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]